okay so i'm going to give you two
examples that are one of which you see
in one which you haven't
um which illustrate this but in a less
obvious way okay
so let's come back to recurrence
relations now obviously
i could go integration by parts but what
happens
it doesn't it doesn't work out great it
does it it's sort of um
it collapses in the heap in a similar
way that our our example just now did
you end up no matter which way you
choose u and dv
it's just an awful mess okay so that
leads you back to this thing and you
think what can i possibly do with this
to make it easier to work with okay
now remember the example i just gave
it was easy because you could see the f
dash and you can see the f
nice and simple okay there's the f dash
there's your f it's a power of nine no
problems okay
now believe it or not there's an f dash
and an f in here
hiding the question is where
now we're going to think about you know
before this example
we avoided the idea of integration by
parts even though it's a product
by using substitution okay the other
handy thing that you can use
is trig identities or really any kind of
identities right but your identities are
particularly useful
i want i've got a whole bunch of tans
here
don't i what's the derivative of tan
it's sex squared isn't it the derivative
of tan equals sec squared
so if i can pull that a sec squared from
here
then i'll be able to see that then i've
got an f dash
and a whole bunch of f's right
that didn't come out right um and then i
can just do the same kind of thing here
i can do it by substitution
okay so how will i get a sec squared
out of this guy how do we usually get
out of tens
i need a tan squared don't i okay so
therefore that leads me to write this
all right tan squared x if i've taken
out two how many do i have left
n minus two of them
okay there you go right i mean so
what's this going to be equal to well we
just said tan squared what's it equal to
in terms of a sec six squared minus one
okay it doesn't look all that nice but
stay with it okay
one of the reasons why i know this is
going to be useful for me is because
this guy
i can express it in terms of i am
because i'm looking for a recurrence
relation
right so he's no problem even though he
looks weird
what happens when i expand this out i'll
just get sec square
tan uh whoops sorry this should be next
there
there's that and then i've got this just
the tan
turn
okay now i'm not worried about this guy
as an integral on his own
he's just what is he he's i
n minus two isn't he because that's what
the power is what about this
well there's my f dash
and there's my f right
so therefore what's this going to be if
i treat them separately
right let's have sec squared there
and i'm going to subtract just like you
told me i n but it's n minus
2. what does this look like do we need
to do the substitution to make sure we
get it right or do you think you can do
it
in your heads i think we can do it right
what are you going to get
when you've integrated this right it's
something to uh
power right so what's going to happen to
it it'll become
m minus one the power goes up x
and then what i have to divide by
n minus one right now just check
if we differentiated to go back would we
get what we expected
you do the inside function which is tan
there's your sec squared that pops out
and then your powers just kind of take
care of themselves don't they so that
looks good
minus this and because i've finished my
um actually i haven't finished my last
integration so i don't need to add a
constant the constant's kind of bound up
in there
okay so there you go that's it
no integration by parts necessary okay
because as you've seen
if you use it at the wrong times uh
yeah you're not gonna have a fun time
okay so there you go